future-tech always comes with two things
promised and unintended consequences and
it's those consequences that I want to
explore and before we get to how future
tech may affect us I'd like to spend a
little time exploring the unintended
consequences of some of our recent
technical
social media a few short years ago was
the tech of future you now it just is
you social media was supposed to bring
us together in ways we could never
imagine and the predictors were correct
these three girls are talking to one
another without the awkward discomfort
of eye contact
I call that advancement we were supposed
to be caught up in a communication
tsunami the likes of which the world has
never seen and that did happen and so
did this one of these things is not like
the other now look at this picture if
you picked the guy with the book you are
wrong or as a certain president would
say wrong
clearly three of these guys are reading
and one guy on the N is listening to the
music and playing candy crush so are we
more connected or are we just more
connected to our devices social media
was supposed to place us in a veritable
town square where we could engage one
another with challenging ideas and
debates and instead what we got were
trolls this is an actual tweet that I
received Chuck no one wants to hear your
stupid ill-informed political views I
hope you get leprosy and die love dad
now the great thing about that tweet if
you look at it just like most trolls
it's not that bad because he wished
leprosy on me instead of leprosy and
leprosy is not dangerous at all along
with trolls we got a brand new way of
torturing teenagers cyberbullying our
concept of my 75 year old mother just
can't seem to wrap her head around so I
said that said did they hit him no mom
they didn't hit him did they take his
money no mom they didn't take his money
they put his face in the toilet
no no mom they did well what did they do
they attacked him on the internet on
internet well why don't you just turn
off the internet
yo-ho generation is a bunch of wussy
she's got a point
she's got a point and I don't even want
to talk about what social media has done
to dating I was on Grindr until I found
out it wasn't a sandwich app
and I can't even tell you about tinder
except for the fact that if you think
that there is a limit to the amount of
anonymous sex we can have on this planet
you are sadly mistaken so where do we go
from here well let's just jump right in
and play the hits driverless cars
something that has already been around
for many many years just without the
assistance of computers because for
years we have been driving while texting
putting on makeup
shaving reading actually reading that
would be me
the other thing is that since driverless
cars will be shared most people won't
own cars and that means the DMV will go
away the DMV I know what you're saying
right now there's no way this guy's
gonna stand up here and make a case for
the DMV well I don't know about you but
I do not want to live in a world where
harsh fluorescent lights endless lines
terrible forms to fill out and
disaffected soulless bureaucrats remind
me that I am pretty damn lucky not to
work here that is the real service they
provide the DMV come for the
registration renewal stay for the
satisfaction of knowing you made some
pretty good life choices
nobody will own their car in the future
and that means teenagers will not have a
place to make out so you know what that
means
that means they will order driverless
cars to do just that
I do not want to step into a vehicle and
ask the question why does this car smell
like awkwardness failure and shame if I
want to ask that question I walk into my
own bedroom so what else do we have to
look forward to that's right artificial
intelligence artificial intelligence yes
you know there was a time when
artificial intelligence was a joke I
mean literally equipped that you would
hear at a cocktail party when somebody
would bring it up in conversation
artificial intelligence
the only real artificial intelligence is
our American Congress it's not funny
anymore Stephen Hawking Elon Musk and
Bill Gates have all gone on record
expressing grave reservations about
artificial intelligence that's like
Jesus Moses and Mohammed coming together
and saying guys guys here's something we
can all believe in you might want to go
with that it's all I'm saying we are
actually teaching machines how to think
how to understand our behavior how to
defend themselves and even practice
deception what could possibly go wrong
the one thing is for sure the creation
always despises its creator okay
the Titans rose up against the gods
Lucifer against Jehovah and anybody who
has a teenager has heard these words I
hate you and you wrote in my life I hate
you now just imagine that sentiment with
a machine that can out thank you and is
heavily-armed the result absolutely what
we need to do before we perfect
artificial intelligence it's perfect
artificial emotions that way we can
teach the robots or machines how to love
us unconditionally so that when they
figure out that the only real problem on
this planet is us instead of destroying
us which by the way is totally logical
they will find us adorable like baby
poop oh my god I just love the way you
destroy the planet I can't can't talk
about this without talking about
robotics okay remember when you thought
robotics were cool I remember when I
thought robotics were cool until I
figured out that they were going to take
everybody's place from the delivery guy
down to the heart surgeon the one thing
though that is very disappointing about
robotics is the holy grail of robotics
and it hasn't even happened I'm talking
about the robot girlfriend the dream of
one lonely geek in a windowless basement
who vowed one day I am going to marry my
creation and there actually is a
movement underway to stop this from
happening for fear of exploitation and I
for one am against that movement I
believe we should have robot girlfriends
I just believed that they should come
with a feminist protocol and artificial
intelligence so she can take one look at
that guy and go I am too good for you
leaving and finally I have to talk about
bio engineering an area of science that
promises to end disease before it even
begins to help us live longer fuller
healthier lives and when you couple that
with implantable hardware you are
looking at the next incarnation of human
evolution and all of that sounds great
until you figure out where it's really
going one place designer babies where no
matter where you are on the globe or
what your ethnicity babies will end up
looking like that
that boy is surprised because he just
found out both his parents are black
if you imagine him at a cocktail party
in 20 years yeah both my parents are
black I mean it's a little awkward at
times but you should see my credit
rating impressive very impressive now
all of this seems scary and everybody in
this room knows that it is it technology
isn't scary never has been and it never
will be what's scary is us and what we
will do with technology will we allow it
to expose our humanity showing our true
selves and reinforcing the fact that we
are indeed our brother's keeper or will
we allow it to reveal our deepest
darkest demons the true question is not
whether or not technology is scary the
true question is how human are you
[Applause]